we woke up this morning and the first
thing we talk about is it's like wow
it's official the Olympic Games are
postponed what does that mean what are
we gonna do tomorrow
you said you know what I think me cantos
today it's absolutely the right decision
the focus wasn't there that obviously
the training facilities weren't there
everything everything screeched to a
halt and you're you know it was the time
for us to focus on family but you're
asking athletes to prepare themselves
for the most important competition you
know of their lives that ring that the
best choice is to do it as I said before
the sooner they can the safer they can
we started also to think of if this
Olympic Games would be really fair if
they asked in July and August for many
reasons like everyone cannot train the
same way to be honest is there's a
little power I mean it's like oh thank
God you know at least we know at least
now we know I know it's the right
decision this is something that's
affecting everybody it would put a lot
of people's health I'd see health and
safety at risk if it moved forward as
planned
how does it made me feel I mean to be
honest I don't think it's fully sunk in
you know it's hard to take a little bit
this was gonna be my last Olympics
I started sport when I was nine years
old with the goal of eventually going to
the Olympics someday and then last year
I punched my ticket and I had I feel
like I had so much to look forward to
going into 2020 I was on camp in Europe
away from my husband for three months
just kind of in the mode where you put
your nose down like it's the final
sprint towards something that you've
been working towards your whole life
and word they're gonna cancel and if
they cancel it for us it's like someone
just oh you know what you go back to the
bottom you start at the bottom the
mountain my personal frustration have to
be put apart for something much more big
training in the in the living home it's
not so easy to fence in the house in the
garage in a very confined spaces is
quite difficult and our fencing trainer
is not with us here a lot a good kit
that we were hoping to use for the
Olympics is now in Japan
I don't own a treadmill um I'm on the
second floor so I don't think the
downstairs neighbors would appreciate if
I got a treadmill we will over the next
few weeks and months be planning on how
how we approach the next year the extra
year if you like we're young we're lucky
we're both healthy and we were kind of
both stepped back and said okay it
doesn't happen now we have more time to
prepare I'm looking forward to spending
some time with my husband there's not
really any way I can isolate away from
him so he will be spending the next 14
days on self-isolation with me so it'll
be nice to have some quality time
together